Donald Trump's former CFO is going to
jail we're talking about Alan
weisselberg he has indeed been sentenced
and this is starting to get closer and
closer and closer to the Inner Circle of
the Trump World CNBC reports former
Trump organization CFO Alan weisselberg
sent to jail for five months in the tax
fraud case former Trump organization
Chief Financial Officer
Alan weisselberg was sent into five
months in jail after pleading guilty to
multiple tax crimes related to former
president Trump's businesses weisselberg
was expected to begin serving as jail
term in New York City's notorious Rikers
Island facility following a sentencing
hearing weisselberg and several of
Trump's business entities were charged
in what prosecutors called a systematic
scheme to defraud state and federal tax
authorities spanning more than 15 years
the article goes on to say that the 75
year old was handcuffed and let out of a
Manhattan courtroom shortly after 2 30
Eastern with a very brief sentencing
hearing before the state judge Juan
Merchant he will be immediately
transported to Rikers Island now some of
you are saying David sir I'm crying
because weisselberg isn't being shipped
up to one of those swankier Federal
facilities my understanding is that
because his sentence is shorter I
believe under a year although fact check
me on that
um he goes to jail rather than prison
and based on the location it's Rikers
which is not exactly a place you want to
spend too too much time if you can avoid
it now of course the questions continue
to be Georgia grand jury is done
and we will soon know whether Trump is
getting indicted there January 6th
committee is done that was in the last
Congress now it's Republicans control
the house January 6 committees done
January 6 Committee of the previous
Congress made a criminal referral of
trump and others to the Department of
Justice we are waiting there to see
whether Merrick Garland will as some
like to say have the testicular
fortitude to charge Donald Trump and
then third we've got things happening in
New York and those relate to Trump's
business in in great part and other
things and there remains a sort of
general question mark as to whether
there may be charges there so we may end
up with no charges against Trump we may
end up with charges from one of these
areas New York Georgia federal charges
could be two and it could be three
if it's three and I don't think that
that's particularly likely what does it
do for Trump's campaign and is Trump
actually looking to bail on the campaign
anyway given how disastrously it's going
questions we will hopefully soon answer
all of the clips I've played here you
can find on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and please please
please make sure
that you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel at youtube.com the davidpackman
show you know there's this thing called
the bystander effect people walk by
someone's being brutally beaten on the
street no one calls the police because
they assume someone else is going to
call real story from history don't allow
the bystander effect of someone else
will subscribe and help them get to 2
million subscribers on YouTube don't
fall for that be the person it costs
nothing it's just a click and you get us
one step closer to an incredible
Milestone two million YouTube
subscribers one of our sponsors today is
Magic spoon the breakfast cereal with
the crunchy sweet goodness you love but
with high quality ingredients less sugar
and more protein magic spoon has zero
grams of sugar it's packed with 13 to 14
grams of protein and just four to five
net carbs so it's great if you're doing
keto or low carb or if just like me
you're trying to limit your sugar intake
they have many unique flavors so you'll
never get bored my personal favorite is
maple waffle but I grew up in New
England so maybe that's why Maple you
know they also have cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry muffin honey nut
cookies and cream cinnamon roll
sometimes there's really just no
substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of
cereal who doesn't love that when the
mood strikes go for something more
wholesome with plenty of protein and
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked simply go to
magicspoon.com Pacman you can create a
custom bundle and use the code Pacman
for five dollars off the link is down
below